[موسيقى]
s
انه الموسم الثامن من نجوم العلوم وفيه
يطل علينا من جديد خالد الجميلي اصعب
اللجان واكثرها حكمه الحكم المواكب لنجوم
العلوم منذ انطلاقته البروفيسور فؤاد مراد
نجمه هذا الموسم رائده الاعمال السيده
عائشه المضاحكه ضيف اللجنه المعتاد
المهندس المعمري الشهير السيد جيمس لو
السلام عليكم متابعي نجوم العلوم اينما
كنتم عبر شاشه الام بي سي 4 من قطر ومصر
والجزائر اجتمعوا سويا تحت سقف واحد
والنتيجه كانت ابتكارات مذهله تعنى
بالمسنين والمتوحدين والرسامين ايضا انها
مرحله تنفيذ النموذج واليوم ثاني تصفياتها
كيف جرت هذه المرحله وما كانت اهم لحظاتها
نتابع مرحله تنفيذ النموذج انطلقت مع
الفريق الاصفر تصفياتها كانت ناريه
واللجنه لم ترحم احد هذه التحديات سخيفه
نحنا بسنه
2016 نقاشاتها غاصت في ادق التفاصيل كيف
تشوف البروت في المستقبل شلون راح يكون
شكله في ختامها شهد الفريق الاصفر خروج
اول ابنائه من المنافسه هزار من تونس في
واحد يمر والاخر ما يمر هذه هي اللعبه
منافسه انتقلت اليوم الى المربع الازرق
مربع احتضن ابنائه الثلاثه لاسابيع
وعراب هذا الفريق خريج الموسم الرابع محمد
وطفه المواجهه الليله تنحصر بالثلاثي عبد
الرحيم برويس وقميص ذكي للمصابين بالتوحد
علي الصليطي واليه البعد الثالث للرسوم
اليدويه احمد الخطاط وحجره استحمام
للمسنين مرحبا بكم نجوم العلوم تضاربت
الاجواء في هذا المربع عبد الرحيم اضاف
بعدا انسانيا منذ البدايه ان الطفل
المتوحد عنده عالم خاص
به كل الاطفال متوحدين في
رابتك اما احمد فما ان وصل حتى قلب كل
الموازين كنا في صمت اول دخول له كله تغير
وعلي بدات اوضاعه شبه ماساويه الاد تبعتك
شوف انا ما بحس تزبط
يعني خبراء الطب والهندسه قدموا الدعم
والتوجيه
وكذلك عمل المصممون على التفاصيل
التصميميه للابتكارات من الوان ومواد تليق
بمنتجات جميله وفعاله مرحله بناء النموذج
لهذا المربع انتهت ولجنه التحكيم
هنا اعضائها الثلاثه الدكتور فؤاد السيده
عائشه والمهندس اللامع جيمس لو تجمعهم
طاوله واحده بالمهندسين
والمصممين
في عمق
الابتات لعله لقاء يكون فيه الحكام فكره
واضحه عن تطور
الابتكارات
الكل مستعد للمواجهه وفي ختامها سنشهد
خروج مشترك اخر من
المنافسه وتصفيات الليله لا قيمه لها لولا
وجودهم نستدعي الان المبتكرين الثلاثه
لبدء
المنافسه من مصر احمد الخطاط يخطو خطاه
نحو مسرح نجوم العلوم مع ابتكار حجره
استحمام للمسنين
[موسيقى]
هذه الجده لطيفه وهذه هرتها فله تعيشان
سويا بسلام وتقضي ان معظم وقتهما على هذه
الكنبه مسلسلات دراميه لا تموت امي صوف
وحياكه والكثير من الكرك للجده والحليب
للهره بين الحين
ياتي امر محتم ليعكر مزاج الجده لطيفه
ومعها الهره فله انه موعد
الاستحمام استحمام الجده لطيفه صار عمليه
دراميه تتطلب ماء وصابو وجهدا وطلبا ليد
العون ايضا احمد فكر بكبار السن وابتكر
غرفه استحمام توفر المساعده الاليه
لاستحمام سهل وامن عبر ضغط وتوزيع الي
منظم للماء يطال الجسم كله ابتكار كبير
بمعناه يرد الجميل لكبار
السن قطر تفخر اليوم بتقديم ولدها علي
الصليطي مع ابتكار اليه البعد الثالث
للرسوم
[موسيقى]
اليدويه نحن معكم اليوم نواكب النجاح
الساحق لتحفه
المالي البعض يريدها ان تنظر اليه من
الجانب الايمن والبعض الاخر من الجانب
[تصفيق]
الايسر دافينشي في
حيره كيف سيحل معضله
[موسيقى]
الموناليزا
من هنا اتت فكره علي وابتكر اليه تضيف
البعد الثالث الى الرسومات اليدويه
الثنائيه الابعاد البعد الثاني لدافنشي
اما البعد الثالث
فلعلي من الجزائر اليكم عبد الرحيم برويس
وابتكار قميس ذكي للمصابين
بالتوحد
[موسيقى]
هذه امل وعمرها لا يتجاوز الثمان
سنوات اللون الازرق
يستهويها عبير الورود يطير بها الى عالم
خيالي امل ليست كباقي الفتيات في عمرها
امل مصابه بالتوحد وهي بحاجه الى رعايه
مستمره واشراف
دقيق من هنا كان ابتكار عبد الرحيم ابتكار
القميص الذكي يمكن الاباء والامهات من
مراقبه حاله اطفالهم عبر تطبيق سواء كانوا
معهم او بعيدين عنهم كما يعطي التوجيهات
والتعليمات عند الضروره للحفاظ على الطفل
بافضل حاله ممكنه ابتكار سيضيف الامل الى
اطفال الع
ماما
دا في الماضي لقي باب الملك غادر عرشه في
نجوم العلوم وعاد اليه اليوم لوضع خبرته
في خدمه المبتكرين انه
الوطف بعد تجربته في نجوم العلوم اسس محمد
اول مدرسه في لبنان لتطبيق تقنيات التعليم
المتطوره عبر ابتكاره شارد واسس ايضا اب
فيجن وهي اول مسابقه للابتكار في دوله
الامارات لطلاب المدارس الثانويه محمد
الهادف دائما الى تطوير اساليب التعليم
للاجيال الصاعده يتابع اليوم مسيره الدعم
والتوجيه في نجوم العلوم هلا اصعب مرحله
ليقبلوا المشتركين شو بده يعملوا
باختراعاتهم ونحن مع بعض ان شاء الله ايدي
بايدهم حنوصل للنهايه مشتاقين وال احنا
اكثر والله الشغل احنا خلص دلوقتي في
مرحله البروتوتايب انت خليكم تعملوا
كونسبت والجين والديزاين كله مع
بض انت حتل مع
منتج
تفضل شكلها اطيب واحده بينتنا رمان لا ده
كيوي ده عصير جزر وشي اورنج عل بفكر ان
احنا بمسابقه مين كتشف شو عم بشرب بدي
اشوفك لما تسع البرايم هلا ودكتور فؤاد
يسالك كم سؤال شو حتعمل شو ايام كنا ببكي
وزعلانين وخايفين انت كلكم مبسوطين وعم
تاكلوا ولا
مين الاول المهم خلص ناخذ علي الاول علي
الاول هو الجو اخوي وهلا اخوي بعدين بكره
بوكسات بالبرايم ها الاهم هلا انه واحد
منكم يدبح لي هالبرنامج طط الثاني وقتها
على ايامي هلا بدي واحد منكم يطلع الاول
بس هيك عاودوا لي اياه هس هي اذا مش انا
اخواني كيف بقولوا خلص في ابدي واحكم يا
خي مشكم
فيكم محمد حياك الله نورت بيتك تمام الله
يحييك انت بين مشتركين عده يعني للامانه
تركوا بصمه جميله من خلال شخصيتهم الرائعه
في برنامج نجوم العلوم والملك انا الملك
انا الملك هو طبعا يعني للعلم محمد جدا
قمه في التواضع لكن من باب الاستفزاز
استفزاز المنافسين كان دائما يستخدم مصطلح
انا الملك الملك شو اخبارك اليوم تمام
الحمد لله امور كلها طيبه محمد شخصيتك انت
كمبتكر او شخصيه اي مبتكر بشكل عام كيف
تلعب دور في نجاح المبتكرين لما يدخلون في
تحدي مع الذات لتنفيذ ابتكار معين اكيد
يعني انا مثل ما قلت قبل شوي انا بحب
التحدي يعني بحبكون الاول علىطول الاول
حتى لو فشلت بحب اوقف وكمان كون الاول دي
ان تبعنا
تبع ان علىطول بدنا نكون ما بقبل الفشل بس
حتى لو فشلنا بوقف على اقوى
وه
بخلينا
العالم يعني اذا في نيه على طول بنلاقي حل
يعني وهذا الشخصيه اللي نحن بنحبها نشوفها
ع بكل المخترعين اللي حوالينا مازات الملك
يا محمد ان شاء الله ان شاء الله وكله
ملوك حوالي كمان ان شاء الله الله يوفقك
ان شاء الله يوفق كل المشتركين اللي معنا
محمد طبعا اليوم راح يغادرنا واحد بس من
المشتركين الثلاثه اللي انت اشتغلت طبعا
معهم وتعرفت عليهم معالم هويه هذا الشخص
اللي للاسف راح يغادرنا راح تبدا بالظهور
ما راح تظهر كليا راح تبدا بالظهور بعد
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
انتظرنا حياكم الله مجددا مع حلول العام
20050 را تتضاعف نسبه سكان العالم اللي
تجاوز اعمارهم 60 سنه من 11% الى
22% في نجوم العلوم هناك من يضع خطه
مستقبليه للعنايه بالمسنين نزار في حاله
لا تسمح له بالاستحمام وحيدا لكنه محرج من
طلب المساعده ويخجل من التعري امام
الاخرين فوجد حل مشكلته باستحداث حجره
استحمام اليه يدخل اليها ويجلس ثم يختار
ما بين نمطي الاستحمام القصير او الطويل
يسترخي نزار ويترك مراحل الاستحمام لتاخذ
مداها حتى عمليه التنشيف يمكنه التدخل
دائما لتعديل حراره الغرفه او ايقاف عمليه
الاستحمام يوفر هذا الابتكار المياه
والطاقه ويحافظ على كرامه المسنين
بتمكينهم من تسيير شؤون حياتهم اليوميه
بمفردهم h2 ابتك اكار انساني يعود الفضل
فيه لاحمد
[موسيقى]
الخطاط بدايه انطلاق المشروع من اعلى نقطه
بش لنا ان احنا نشتغل بالهمه العاليه
حضرتك مبتسم على طول شو انت المساهمه
الفعليه اللي ناوي انت تعملها غير الخبراء
ا هيدا الجواب اه فرجاني انها كثير جاهز
مش عارف اجمع بسرعه الافكار اقول
ايه احمد مغرور انت يا جوس
بتخبي ه الغرور بهال
الابتسامه الماسك صيب في
الشنطه انت عم تعمل جهاز للاستحمام
للمسنين او اصحاب الحاجات الخاصه بس بده
يكون متحرك الريجيم اللي بدك تحطه
البروجرام كيف الواتر جيتس بدها تغير
اتجاهات وسرعه وغيره تتوصل لعمليه تنظيف
كامله لكل الجسم لانه في عندك عمليه تنشيف
كمان ان شاء الله واضح الامور تمام
بالتوفيق مرحبا بكم في يوم جديد من نجوم
العلوم يو مليء بالحيويه والنشاط
والابداعات اول ما بدخل على اللاب طبعا
نبدا بالتحيه الصباحيه نورت المكان نورت
المكان الله يخليك انا داخل مكان في نور
بوجودكم وبعدين بنبدا فنجان القهوه فلنبدا
الصباح بكوب من النسكافي وبعدين نبدا نبلش
الشغل على طول ونطلق رصاصه
البدء
يلا
oh we can't from scratch we bought him
walk you are suggesting water flow going
through a nozzle the water going in is
being spread out and it becomes this
dusty kind of spray how
call النظر تمثل المحور الاساسي في الجهاز
لان هي اللي عن طريقها هتتم عمليه التنظيف
وهتدي احساس الراحه للشخص اللي هو داخل
الشاور
one things that is keeping us is choice
no
how المهمه الان هي اختيار المرشه
المناسبه وفحص ضغطها للمياه ومساحه
التغطيه
the no that showed like more of the m
effect
i دلوقتي هنتبر مد فعاليه الرشاشات في
كفائتها في التنظيف تجارب مطوله اجراها
احمد مع المصممين لتحديد دوره الاستحمام
المناسبه لناحيه الوقت
والنظافه
[موسيقى]
انا مش بتعامل مع انسان او بشر عادي
بتعامل مع ناس كبار السن زي ما انا بحفظ
كرامتهم فلازم برض احفظ استجابتهم
للجهاز بشكله اي واحد يظن ان هو سهل لكن
اللي يخش في التفاصيل التكنيك بتاعته
والبب والور والحاجات دي لا معقده جدا
مهام كثيره بانتظار احمد تصنيع
الهيكل طباعه
المرشات اضافه الغطاء وا كل ذلك يجري
تحضيرا لموعد التجارب المقرره لاختبار
فعاليه حجره الاستحمام على ارض
الواقع في حاله
are we ready need toose the cover
sh gna look around to see if we see
leakages
wel start the pump in one two
three stop ok stop stop
stop
syem
لازم
تتحل ان شاء الله نقعد للفجر لخلص الس
مشاكل اللحظه الاخيره استغرقت الليل كله
لحلها حس باجهاد الله عيرك يا انا كنت
عامل تجارب كتير قي نجربها عليه نعمل كل
التجارب دي اتمنك انت وعلي التوفيق ان شاء
الله ربما انت اللي توصل
[موسيقى]
في قلق شديد دي اخر تجربه ما فيناش نعيد
تاني الحمدلله ال
زبط لحظه الحسم حانت وفيها اثبات فعاليه
حجره الاستحمام في
[موسيقى]
ting
so and then theer
pumping let's do
dr
open
ابتكار انساني يعود الفضل فيه لاحمد
[موسيقى]
الخطاط 2050 ح نكون بحاجه كلنا له الجهاز
ما ان شاء الله ربنا ما يخليش حد يحتاجه
ان شاء الله ويكون كلنا في صحه
وشباب حاله الدنيا هي حاله الدنيا انا
ماشي بالطريق قبلك بس ت وصل ل 2050 عن قدر
حالي وين بصير ما بعرف اذا راح فيني امشي
مثل هذا الشخص يلي مشي علق الثياب تبعه
وفتح الباب وقعد يعني اللي قادر يعمل هيك
يمكن قادر
يتحمم تقديري انا بس تصير سنه 2050 يمكن
بكون انا مقرب صوب هيدا الحمام الحجره
هنسميه على كرسي في لها عجلات مش كل كبار
السمبي مش قادرين يتحركوا لا في ناس
بيتحركوا بس بقى الحركه بتاعتهم سلو
وبسيطه وضعيفه بيتحركوا ويقدروا يعملوا
الحاجات الاساسيه انا ما بقولش شخص مقعد
يعني بالنسبه لي سنه 2016 اليوم ما راح
استعملها بس يمكن بال 2020 بلش استعمل
هالجهاز 2050 بدي جهاز اخر اذا ضليتني على
الارض
الصح
اول تجربه احنا كنا حطينها ان احنا لازم
نجرب السيستم على دومي لسبب بسيط ان انا
عاوز اشوف اللي هو امسك الدومي اوسخ توسيخ
جامد احط عليها ست من كل حته واشوف الافيش
بتاع التنظيف
نفسها you will know is effective for
cleaning it
comfortable does it feel safe does it
give you dignity is a
dignity all of those things cann be
tested with a dummy you made a product
for old people that you yourself are not
willing to
ins تمام انا دوقتي لو انا دخلت جو
السيستم بنفسي انا ازاي هقول ان انا نظيف
هذا جواب يعني تخذ عليه صفر صفر صفر
بالمره لانه انت عندك خطه مبوط وخطه كانت
واضحه ببلش ب بعدين بتبلش بعنصر شاب انت
بعدين بتروح انسان مسن انت
رحتم حالك ورحت دغري للانسان
المسن حالك من هذا الفحص لانك اما فزعان
ما يحرقك النشاف لا اطلاقا او انت بتفزع
تفوت فيه من ما يلط عك شريت كهربا
مثلا شو القصه ليش ما عندك جواب ل ما را
نقضي كل الجلسه لا ل ل ل جواب جواب سريع
جواب سريع اه الجواب السريع ان انا كنت
فعلا جايب اللبس السباح اللي كنت هجربه في
نفس اليوم وكان لسه في بعض الحاجات الليج
والحاجات كان السيستم لسه مش رض
bearing swimming trunks in studio you
in that machine
flow working with your team which jets
pointing which dire which temperature is
right that is how you make this design
you
can
عمليه
احمر لا لا هو انا لغايه دلوقتي مازال لسه
لباس البحر معايا في السياره لغايه
دلوقتي اوي بليز يس اوكي ممكن اوف اه انا
مستعد اه انت جاهز اه والله
جاهز طيب يلا اطلع من هون دغري على الشاور
يلا لا بس هم بس حط عشان لا ما راح نجيب
الشاور لهون انت روح لعنده طب متوصل هو هو
موصل وكل شي انت قعد بقلبه وتوكل على الله
اجيب بس قعد بقلبها وتوكل على الله مثل ما
انت يلا روح ازي توكل على الله توكل على
الله يلا
[تصفيق]
بال احمد متحمس الله يعينه ويوفقه ان شاء
الله هو باقي اخوانه العموم الماليزا من
اشهر اللوحات في العالم للرسام الايطالي
دافنشي فيها الكثير من الاسرار واولها
نظره عيونها اللي تتابع المشاهد اينما ذهب
ما يجعل دافنشي رائد الرسم الثلاثي
الابعاد قبل اكتشافه بقرون الابتكار
التالي قد يجعل كل منا دفنشي عص خلونا
نشوف هذا وليد وهو يود تحويل الرسومات
اليدويه السطحيه الثابته الى
الحاسوب يحاول رسم الواجهتين الاماميه
والجانبيه للوجه البشري يقوم البرنامج
بتكثيف عموديا ثم تقوم خوارزميه علي بدمج
الاحجام واستخراج الكتله
المشتركه النتيجه تصور ثلاثي الابعاد يعكس
واجهتي الرسم تبعا لزاويه النظر 2 3 دي
فكره مبدعه من ابتكار علي
[موسيقى]
اليطي كيف جهزت حالك من وقت نا عليك
بالكاست الحمدلله انا جاهز وراح اقنع كل
اللي معاي ان مشروعي جاهز للتنفيذ استيك
على فعل اقنع ما بيهمني اقنع بيهمني نفذ
انا تركت كورس كامل من دراستي لكن راح
اعوض هذا الشي بالفوز بنجوم العلوب علي
كيف تتعامل مع انفعالاتك اذا شفت ان اللي
انا قاعد اسويه هو الصح اكمل ما عليه من
الناس عندك عناد
نعم برنامج اللي انت جاي تعمله هون بتاخذ
الواجهه وبتاخذ الجانب اورج ه هذا
البرنامج لازم يخيطه سوا ويعمل تخمين تطلع
منه ما يوازيه بالبعد الثلاثي دكتور عزام
هو المشرف الرئيسي يعني ما بيتغير شيء
بالبرنامج الا ما هو يوافق عليه بس انت
بتتحمل مسؤوليه
قرارك وايضا هون هذا بس نبي نثبت الفكره
وارويك بور بوينت عن هذه الجهه الاماميه
وعندي الجهه اليمنى راح نحط المكعب في
النص وشوي شوي احنا نتحكم في النقاط لين
ما نكون الشكل يعني ونشكل احم تحكي
اوتماتك ايو اوتوماتيك ما فيك اوتوماتك
علي منه بروجرامر سو مش عارف اللي بيقدر
ينعمل من اللي ما بيقدر ينعمل كل شيء انه
الكمبيوتر ما حيقدر يعرفه غير عن هول ما
تم الايديا تبعتك شوف انا ما بحسها را
تزبط يعني لقينا مشاكل في الموضوع فانا
ودي اشد حيلي واحاول اني اقلل وقت
النوم انام الساعه 9 ص واقوم الساعه 3 ونص
على اساس نحل المشاكل ونبعد عنها علي اي
ساعه بتفيق الصبح ا الصبح ضروري تفني معك
يعني اي والله علي متصل فيني الساعه 35 اي
ام الصبح مكول انه انت في يعني شي عم
اقوللك شو علي خناقنا على الاخير تجربتي
كلها ماشان طالب ينادي المنتور عند
الرابعه صباحا هذا الديك وما يفعلها
اخي تجارب مطوله مع
الخبراء كثيره مع المصممين ومن حيث لا
ندري انهى علي عمله بفكره غير
[موسيقى]
متوقعه را يطلع معه شي غير انه يحول مضبوط
من 2دي ل 3 دي عم يطلعوا
معك ولا شي تبط معك كتون ممكن تبط معك بس
انه كفيس فيسز مضبوطه ما بيطلع ماني مقتنع
فيها كثير صراحه هي هيدي واضحه
يعني نحن ويك يعني هو خلص قال لي لا بدي
هذا الموض اوكي خلص اذا متفقين انت مسؤول
عن الخيار وتدافع عن هذا الخيار امام لجنه
الحكم اوي ما يهمني حد يعني اذا هو مقتنع
مش مقتنع ما دام انا جربتها ونجحت انتم
تشتغلون عليها ونجح ان
[موسيقى]
شاء
اكتشفت ما يحتاجون مثل هذ البرامج ممكن
بسهوله يس الاشياء عد
اسويها
احضر الخبير اول نموذج ابتكار لعلي هذا
مثل ما بدي
نوشن كلش ماقدر بعمل
ابكيشن بدك تعرف الاشياء في اشياء بتشوفها
سهله بتكون صعبه لا في اشيا احنا نصعب لا
ما
[موسيقى]
فيك استراتيجيتك تنفذت صح تنفذت بس
التفاصيل المواد ما تطلع مش عارف ليش يعني
لانه العيب با استراتيجيتك مش اليوم
بيجيني ايميل بيقول انا ه ماني مقنع
بشغلهم بدي اتعرف على مبرمج محلي ونبلش عن
جديد ومعنا
اسبوعين نحن ببرنامج علمي في ماجيك وان
ولا بحف هذا الفانوس السحري وبيطلع واو
بينجو انا بحترم شغل غيري واختصاص غيري
هذا واحد عم يتهرب من المسؤوليه وما بده
يكون مسؤول عن الكلام اللي حكيت وقلت خلص
يعني النتيجه محسومه يعني انا انا برعت
المسابقه ما تبلش من الصفر وبني مع افضل
واحد ممكن يساعدك وفهمان شو عم تعمل
الموضوع هو مينتور اسر دكتور اسمر بعد ما
راح ما قدرت امسك نفسي صحتي يعني انا صحتي
يعني املي في هال الاسبوعين اذا نجحت
انجحت ما نجحت خلاص يعني ما
تركب اشتغلنا سهرنا على اساس نطلع باخر
نتائج نقدر عليها في خلال اسبوعين ابشركم
اشتغل التحويل
الحمدلله طلعت النتيجه اللي ما احد توقعها
اصلا صار عندنا منتج واعطيناه اسم 2 3 دي
يلخص ايش هو المشروع عمري 22 سنه طلعت
باختراع صرت منافس قوي والمتسابقين يحسبون
لي الف حساب اطلب مقابله دكتور
فؤي ان شاء الله يقنع الدكتور فؤاد
والحكام لهم وان شاء الله اكون من
الفايزين جايين اليوم نعمل التست مشان
السوفتوير تبع علي فينا نجرب حاله رسمي
فيني اعملها السايد وفي نعملها الفرونت
فيفت هو راح يعمل اوتوماتيك كونفرجن لث دي
مديل نقي شي رسمي من هون هي خلينا نرسم
هيدي هي
الفيس نرسم ثاني
عين ت سي شو را يطلع معنا هون عننا المخ
ما رجعوا بينوا بينين فوق بعض
ح شغان انا را اخذ م رسمه هيك موجوده عننا
ه وفيني اخذ السي
تبع كان يرس بس نعمل هي المفروض
اليف من هون طلعت بعد شفنا يرسم ه لايكون
يعرف يرسمو نفس الرس تع رسمناها
وحط
تجربتي معك حلوه ومره بس انا بدي ابلش معك
بالشيء الحلو انك انت تمتلك كل شخصيه
المبتكر والمخترع والريادي لانه بده يكون
واحد عنده هالقد باشن للي عم يعمله وماني
مقابل حدا بثمان سنين مقتنع
بفكرته وحابب ينفذها قدك انت بقى من من
هالناحيه بهنيك حاولت انا امبارح مع جيمز
زميلي قلنا بدنا نجرب المنتج اللي عم تحكي
عنه قعدت انا م قبيله وانت بدك تفسر لي شو
صار
رسمني ب على الطريق الجانبيه وضخم الانف
تبعي لانه هو بحبني كثير ضخ ضخم الانف ما
بعرف شو كان هدفه من الموضوع بس انه رسم
رجع قال لي استدير استدرت ورسم الواجهه
تبعي وضخم الاذنين كمان عنده هدف ثاني من
اللعبه هيدي ولكن انا مسامحه من بعد ما
عمل رسم وهو زلمه موهوب صح و وفنان هل
البرنامج تبعك لانه الحلول كثيره راحت لحل
هو كاشف النفوس يا هل ترى لانه راحت راحت
لما يعادله في ثلاثيه الابعاد لشيء ما
بيشبهني ولا بيشبه حدا بالعائله يعني يعني
يعني شيء حتى يمكن طلع وجه
ل لشيء بيمشي على اربعه اجرين بس الاحجام
نفسها يعني حجم الراس اللي يرسمك فيها هو
نفسه يعني نفسه يوم تبرمه الدوره نفس الشي
الاحجام لكن يعني البرنامج تبعك كشف له
نيته اللي رسمه بالضبط يعني جيمز ه هي
الحقيقه being driven is not a solution
to finding the realities of your project
i think you don't actually
understand what you are trying to do and
i explain to you i'm an
architect when i design a building the
building looks different on all sides we
cut one ax we cut another ax that only
gives
building
sides sides infinite number of sides if
we take a
face when we scan a face we scan it
almost thousand and thousands of scans
all the way around in order to create
the three
dimensional
resu
form there
is artificial intelligence that can take
this data and this data and fill up
everything in
between that is why i think you are a
young man that has a big
idea but you don't understand
idea and you use determination to fight
fight
fight people whatever to try convince
people is the
way but future lies in letting go and
understanding what you really want to
achieve
understand somebody
youm you jump in
the بس هلنا انته الوم لمين وكيف استخدامه
نعم الغير نعم الغير المحترفين للاطفال
للاطفال من سن ثمان سنوات الى 16 سنه
المراهقين وهو هدفه اثراء الخيال والابداع
لدى الاطفال يرسمون اي شيء يتخيلونه يطلع
لهم مجسم يرسمون ويشوفوا شو بطلع لهم هذا
البرنامج واحد من الحلول الفنت حلول اللي
ممكن نلاقيها ويطلع شي كاركتر ما خمن و هو
بسبي فن وضحت الصوره لعبه مسليه بتطلع شي
قريب للي بلشنا فيه بالرسم اليدوي ولكن ما
في وعد باي شيء باي مواصفات لذلك انت اللي
لعبته امبارح بهذ الرسومات تبعك علي انا
اوكي كثير بعيده عن الواقع واوعى تاخذها
معك سوفنير على تشاينا وضحه الصوره جاهزين
نعطيه علامات من
مخيلتنا لعلي اتمنى لك توفيق يعطيك
العافيه
شكرا كل التوفيق لعلي ان شاء الله محمد
طبعا قاعدين نشوف المواجهات هذه وانت احد
الاشخاص اللي مريت في مثل هالمواقف هذه
وكانت عسيره في بعض الاوقات كنت تطلع
الاول في بعض الاوقات بعد ما طلعت من
برنامج نجوم العلوم دمجت التعليم في حياتك
العمليه في البزنس دمجت التعليم في مجال
التكنولوجيا بشكل بشكل قوي جدا بشكل واضح
واتخذت من هذا
الامر مصدر دخل بزنس سم هي ما
تسميه
هل يعني انت في طريقك الى ان انت تعوض
وجود البشر في المدارس
بالتكنولوجيا هذا منحنى خطير اذا بتسويه
اكيد راح يزعلون منك كل المدرسين انا واحد
منهم انا واحد منزعل من نفسك انت بعد 100%
الايديه انه بدي
اعمل يعني بدي ادمج العالم الافتراضي
والعالم الفيزيكال لهون على الاستاذ ليعلم
يعني انا هلا هد الاول انه التكنولوجيا
نحن عايشين بعالم تكنولوجيا والاستاذ اللي
ما بيعرف بالفي ريالتي بالاد ريالتي بكل ه
التكنولوجيا بالهولوجرام
بالتك ه التكنولوجيا موجودين ليساعدوا
الاستاذ ليوصل المعلومه
للتلميذ الطلاب هلا عايشين بعالم
تكنولوجيا كله عنده ايباد وايفون اذا
الاستاذ ما في يستعمل التكنولوجيا ليخدمه
ليوصل هالفكره بون استاذ اوديت فهمت علي
كيف سو انا هدفي هلا ان كيف استعمل
التكنولوجيا اللي طلعتها من نجوم العلوم
وع عملت منها مدرسه يعني وكيف استعمل
تكنولوجيا غيرهم لساعد الاستاذ ليعلم
طلابه سو التكنولوجيا مش حيحل محل الاستاذ
التكنولوجيا حيساعد الاستاذ ليعلم الجيل
الجديد وجيلنا نحن هلا موجودين تكنولوجيا
اداه يعني صارت اداه مين تو ان اند هي
وسيله لغايه هي منها غايه بحد ذاتها سو
هيدا تدمج استاذ منيح مع تكنولوجيا منيحه
مع
بعضهم نحنا هي عايشين فيه دكتور محمد احبب
اقوللك اطمنك طبعا في مخترع نجوم العلوم
محمد وطفه ما يسعى ان يستبدل البشري
بالاله 100% فارتاح وظيفتك موجوده ان شاء
الله امورك طيبه يعطيك العافيه اللجنه
طبعا بانتظار مواجهه عبد الرحيم واحنا
اكيد بانتظار معرفه هويه المستبعد من
هالمرحله وكل ذلك راح يحصل بعد هذا الفاصل
الاخير
انتظرونا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد مبتكر الكهرباء توماس
اديسون عبقري الموسيقى بتهوفن مخترع شخصيه
مون اللي هو الياباني ساتوشي تاجيري كلهم
ابدعوا رغم معاناتهم من التوحد ومن التوحد
ايضا كان الابتكار الاتي تمضي رهام نهارا
عاديا وهادئا تستمتع
بوقتها لكن هذا الهدوء سرعان ما انقلب الى
اضطراب فانزلقت ريهام الى عالم افتراضي
لدى سماعها صوت الصافره لم يشغل هذا
التحول بال والدتها لان رهام تلبس قميصا
ذكيا للاطفال المتوحدين ابتكره عبد الرحيم
ليقوم بتشخيص حالتها انيا عبر حساسات
مدموجه في قميصها ينبه والدتها عن بعد
باستخدام تطبيق للهواتف الذكيه مقترحا
الاسلوب المناسب للمساعده من خيار التهدئه
او التمارين وفي القميص ايضا هزازات
واضواء مثبته باحكام لتتيح امكانيه
المساعده الاليه الى حين التدخل البشري
مبتكر قميص المتوحدين وندر كت هو عبد
الرحيم
برويس هذه مسابقه مسابقه فريده من نوعها
واحد منكم بيفل بوقفتك شايفك انك انت اكثر
شيء مسامح انا اعرف فين رايح واعرف هدفي
واعرف الطريقه التي توصلني للهدف الذي انا
بدي اوصل له في منافسه شرسه بلا تسام وعد
من
عندي عبد الرحيم عندك صفات التوحد بتحب
تكون لوحدك عندك خجل اجتماعي مشروعك هو
لتتحدى نفسك مشروعي هو لتحدي
الفشل فكره الاختراع هي قميص ذكي وتفائلي
لاطفال التوحد الهدف منه هو مساعده
العائلات في وكيفيه التعامل معهم في
المنزل خارج على المركز يعني القميص تبعت
هندس مثل كانه للاهل كيف يتصرفوا مع
والدور الثاني هو الكال انا
ايي سنت
الفكره اذا ما في لكل شي بعمله بالمركز ما
كانه عم نعمل شي شرف ان اكون يوما ما اخدم
هذه الفئه صراحه فان افكر ليل نهار في
المشروع وانجاح بصك عم تحضر لهذا المنتج
اكثر من سته اشهر واليوم ببلش ننفذ معك رح
يكون في خبير بومك انجين اسمه زياد ما
بيتغير شي بالمشروع الا ما هو يوافق عليه
صباح الخير خبرتي كمنور تعطينا نوع من
الاسلوب للتعاطي مع اي شخص مطلق عنده فكره
اكيد فيي اللي نحن من طريقه علميه لازم
نعالجها سؤال هون شو بتعطي فايبريشن
الانترفال هل هي بتعملها سكوير وايف انه
دقيقه ايه دقيقه لا عطت انذار وعطت انذار
وعطت انذار ومرض اليرنس شو اللي كلينكل
لازم ينعمل ليش ما عم
تكتب دكتور زياد يتعامل مع البحث بطريقه
اكاديميه لانه هو شغله مبني على هذه الاسس
انا مش رافض للاشياء ومش معاند لكن ف اخذ
ورد لكي اكون مقتنع بالفكره من فضلك
اعطيني دقيقه اتكلم على المشكل اللي انا
فيه الان نحنا مقيدين استاذ بوق اذا انا
جدج وجاوبني ه الجواب بالفاينل بتاخذ 3
على
50 صعب كثير الشخص يجتهد كثير ويقدم اللي
هو عليه لكن يفهم بطريقه اخرى لازم تضغط
تضغط حالك شوي عبد الرحيم اخذ بنصيحه احمد
ولكن احمد لا يعي انه سيكون حقل تجارب
لعبد الرحيم احمد ممكن نجرب عليك ا طب انه
هذه اخر الرتوشات شوف كيف جاته شو جمي
ممتاز اجلسه الكيفيه وتقوم
بالروك ا
ابدا اكمل عبد الرحيم التجارب الاوليه
لبرمجه
ابتكاره
كان كل تركيبه خاطئ انا مضطر الان ننزع
هذا من جديد ونشوف الخيوط بس عندك خبره
الخياطه لو كانت معي امي ل
سعدت انا عندي شغل اخر نقوم به مش الخياطه
القميص اصبح جاهزا للتجربه الفعليه على
ولد مصاب
بالتوحد
want len tr
on get us to it get us to it come
[موسيقى]
on الفعل الاوليه لم تكن مطمئنه لعبد
الرحيم استجمع عبد الرحيم قواه واستكمل
العمل تحضيرا لتجربه القميص على عدد من
الاطفال المتوحدين لجمع المعلومات حول
كيفيه تفاعل هذا القميص مع حاله كل منهم
نحن بمرحله الديش ب نشوف كل الستيج تبع
السيستم اذا شغاله او لا ببلش بالمون
بعدين
كانت النتائج جدا رائعه وكان الجهاز دقيق
وكان يعطي تعليمات على حسب الليفل اوف
اكتيفيتي للطفل المتوحد صراحه تجربه رهيبه
وصلت الى هدفي عندي ايمان كبير جدا انه
سوف ترون هذا المشروع منتج بعد جمع
المعلومات حول القميص حان موعد التجربه
الفعليه لاثبات كفاءته مع
المختصين st
stun remove it one second but he want to
remove it take it
run was
soed the
inter
and فريق التصوير والكاميرات عوامل ربما
اثرت في رده فعل الولد حول القميص لنتيجه
عادله قررنا اعاده جربه بعيدا عن ايه
عوامل مؤثره تجربه سجلت بهدوء عبر كاميرات
المراقبه كان
في صار في
منه
فيه بنفس الوقت كانوا
على وحده
وحده اليوم بعتبر الدرت نجحت بالشن تست
تبع بروتايب وصارت ريدي للمرحله الثانيه
اللي هي
التصنيع عبد الرحيم انت عامل قميص ذكي ماك
عامل عائله قمصان ذكيه عامل قميص كيف ه
القميص الذكي بدك تبيعه وبدك تعرضه للناس
وانت بتعرف انه هيدي لانه مساعد نفساني
هيدي شغله شخصيه كثير وتختلف من شخص اخر
فيك تقول لي كيف كيف دمجته بما انه هذا
الاختلاف الذي اوافقك فيه الراي كبير
ويختلف من فئه الى فئه خاصه في امراض
التوحد ف قاموا العلماء في ميدان التوحد
بوضع اسس او ستاندرز فاحنا ايش فعلنا
استغل هذا المانيوال هذه الطريقه اللي اهد
فيها العلماء وحولنا الى طريقه ع اليه
تظهر او ترشد المكلفين بعنايه الطفل
المتوحد في كيفيه التعامل مع الطفل
المتوحد انزين ممكن تشرح لنا شوي تجربتك
مع البروتوتايب انت جربته مع اطفال التوحد
اشوف انه كان صعب انهم يتقبلون التيشيرت
اطفال فيئه التوحد صعب عليهم يندمجوا مع
وسط جديد او لباس جديد او اي شيء جديد
ضيفه له ولهذا السبب انا فكرنا في وضع هذه
الديبل بارت معناها في البدايه يتجرب
القميص لوحده بدون الجزء الذكي مع يلبس
الطفل القميص لوحده يدرب عليه لمده مثلا
لا ارب ايام خه ايام الى حب القميص احنا
نضيفه فهذه من بين من بين الاشياء اللي
ضفها لصعوبه التاقلم مع اي شي
[موسيقى]
جديد
cho
treatment and sends back the
architecture
system
automatic
treat
tey great
val لو احنا اردنا ان نجعل القميص يقوم
بمعالجه اي حاله يقع فيها الطفل متوحد
فكن على يقين سيدي الكريم انه سوف يكون
اكثر من 100 طريقه حل او 100
طريقه علاج وهذا اي قميص اظن يعجز على
القيام بهذا
الشي
could
حاولت ان شاء الله تكون اقنعتنا وهون
العلامات بتميزك بشوف اذا تلك معنا
بعرف
شك
الله يقك ان شاء الله يا عبد الرحيم اعضاء
لجنه التحكيم ارجو البدء الان بتقييم
الشباب اللي بانتظار نتائجهم نذكر بان
واحد بس راح يغادر
البرنامج شكرا لاعضاء لجنه التح حكيم اطلب
الان من جميع المشتركين احمد وعلي وعبد
الرحيم بالوقوف امام اعضاء لجنه التحكيم
للاعلان عن
النتائج احمد من مصر علي من قطر ومن
الجزائر عبد الرحيم خلوني راح ابدا اعطيكم
بس الارقام المركز الاول كم خذ والثاني كم
خذ والثالث كم خذ راح ابدا من تحت المركز
الثالث خذ
46 المركز
الثاني حصل على
58.7 اما المركز الاول حصل على
81.7 واحد منكم راح يغادر راح ابدا الان
باعلان عن صاحب المركز
الاول عبد الرحيم من
الجزائر
مبروك يا عبد
الرحيم علي مطاطا راسك لكن طقطقه الراس
ممكن تكون لي حزن على المغادره ممكن تكون
ايضا بنفس الوقت تواضعا بالفوز والتساهل
للمرحله اللي بعدها احمد ابتسامتك ما تروح
ما تتوتر طبيع ما تخاف طبيع الحمد
لله تستاهل يا احمد انتقالك لمرحله اللي
بعد
علي هارد لاك وحظ موفق باذن الرحمن خارج
اسوار نجوم العلوم اذا مشاهدينا الكرام
تاهلوا احمد وعبد الرحيم الى المرحله
المقبله مرحله تقيييم الاسواق اذا فريق
اخير سيعيش هذه اللحظات الصعبه خلال
الاسبوع المقبل الى حينها تابعونا عبر
الموقع الالكتروني للبرنامج ستارز s.com
وصفحات التواصل الاجتماعي فيسبوك تويتر
وانستغرام
نراكم ان شاء الله باذن الرحمن في الاسبوع
المقبل الان استودعكم الله على الحب
التقينا على الود دائما نلتقي في امان
الله مبروك
احم رحله قويه
[موسيقى]
جداو
a
[موسيقى]
متسابقين في نجوم العلوم عشنا معاهم لمده
شهرين وصرنا على قلب واحد انا شايل هم
فراق علي لما وضعوا الربورتاج الخاص بك
والله الدموع ده نزل يا الله كيف المراحل
مراحل مخترع بدات من فكره مشاكل بكاء
تواسوني بعد
مشروعي صغير سوف يفار صراحه يعني ايام ما
راح انساها وراح اطلع من نجوم العلوم ذكرى
طيبه وخبرات
[موسيقى]
كبيره